well thomas frank is with us this
morning he's the author of this book
what's the matter with Kansas how
conservatives won the heart of America
good morning mr. Frank how you doing
fine what happened what happened what
happened the election the election that
mirrored what you wrote about in this
book it's kind of funny what happened in
the election is what happened to Kansas
about 15 years ago isn't it it's a you
know the the sort of moderates and the
centrist just absolutely swamped by the
right and it should be you know the
thing is that this should be it
shouldn't be a surprise to anybody
anymore this kind of thing goes on it's
been happening since well the phenomenon
that we saw last Tuesday you know of
people voting for their values over
their economic interests or you know in
a very rough sense has been going on
since 1968
okay the Republicans the Conservatives
have been using the wedge issues the
culture war issues with great effect
ever since then what astonishes me is
that the democrats still don't really
have a way of diffusing this they don't
they don't seem to understand what's
happening to them and why and it keeps
happening it happens every four years it
happens again
it's very very frustrating but so what
happened in Kansas what my book is about
is about the sort of the the ongoing
power of these issues and the sort of
the kind of right-wing populist revolt
that you see sweeping across states like
Kansas and much of the middle of America
and ironically states that were once
very liberal if not outright radical you
actually get some history where Kansas
was liberal yeah well I wouldn't say
liberal it was it was a it was radical a
hundred years ago Kansas was well it
goes back further than that the state
was it was settled by of abolitionists
and Free Soilers that went there
deliberately to block people slave
owners from Missouri moving west and in
the 1890s the state was swept over by a
what they called populism which is a
sort of radical movement of farmers and
workers and you know this is very
inspiring moment
all my life I've read books about
populism and always thought gee what you
know what a great moment that was and
then and then Kansas remained it's after
that it was always Republican Kansas has
always been loyal to the Republican
Party because of its civil war you know
its origins in the civil war but it was
a different sort of republicanism it
personified by people like William Ellen
White who was by today's standards on
the left or Alf Landen even who was the
Republican candidate in 1936 but again
by today's standards very moderate or
too liberal or even Dwight Eisenhower
you know so but but in in in recent
years the state has moved further and
further to the right and all based on
values issues the the you know the
culture war issues and that's that
fascinates me so it's a in-depth study
of that why did you choose Kansas as
kind of a microcosm these others of
what's going on in these states well for
one thing cuz it's my home state so it's
so it made it easy to do the research
because I still you know I have I have
friends there and it's a you know and
it's a place that's always fascinated me
it's my home state and its story is
rarely told you know that sort of thing
but it's also Kansas is traditionally
used by journalists as a microcosm of
America it's the most average place in
America this is you know this is because
it's right in the middle you know but
also statistically if you look at the
numbers it actually is very close to the
average you know in any ranking of the
states it's always number 25 except for
in tourism where it's absolutely last
because it's so familiar you've been
there you know you see what you know
what Kansas is like it's like everywhere
else and Soho so back to the killing of
course I realize that so back to this
election what why did people vote
against their economic interest in your
opinion well it's that's it's a that's a
big question and it takes me 300 pages
to answer it in in in the book and so
I'll try to give you the condensed
version and the bottom line is this that
the conservative movement the Republican
Party also in America have been very
successful at describing at reaching out
to blue-collar voters
and describing themselves as
representatives of the angry hard done
by average American and this is the this
is the essential point about the culture
wars that people that liberals and
Democrats never seem to understand that
this is really about class that in some
ways all of all of these things are a
way of talking about class without
talking about the economic aspect of
class and it's very it's very obvious if
you you know watch Bill O'Reilly or read
their their books or something like that
these people talk about class all the
time but these people I mean
conservatives talk about class all the
time in Kansas that divide you can see
it on the map the divide between oh
dammit there's very few Democrats there
are very even fewer liberals the main
divide is between your old-school
moderate Republicans and your
conservative Republicans and the divide
is between working-class neighborhoods
and or you know affluent upper
middle-class neighborhoods so if it you
know that's that's a that's to make the
a very very very long story short that's
what it's about it's about this kind of
cultural populism and you've been seeing
it every four years for some time yeah
more or less yeah well I mean we can go
back over the elections and talk about
the issues so and so in four years what
does what do Democrats need to do to
change it so this is where I'm good sigh
I know I'm out of my element
I I'm uh you know I'm fundamentally I'm
a kind of a person that looks backward
historian and I like talking about the
past and talking about the future is
more difficult for me and also I should
point out that I just moved to DC I'm
not from here I don't understand this
town and and I'm no good at pulls and
I'm no good at you know national
political strategy but I can say in the
in the big cultural battle the the great
you know war of position that goes on
between the two parties the Democrats
have to come up with a way to defuse
culture war populism they have to come
up with India and it seems to me that
the obvious way is and this should be
easy for the Democrats because once upon
a time they had a very clear and
straightforward way
of talking to blue-collar voters that
was them that was who they were think of
Franklin Roosevelt Harry Truman from
Kansas City this was that's who
Democrats were and they have to recover
that that that way of speaking to those
people to those voters they have to be
able to challenge this kind of phony
culture war populism where it's all
about the liberal elite and the people
with their Volvo's and their sushi
you've heard this critique they have to
be able to challenge that with the real
deal with real populism and talk about
who really runs our country and who
really you know benefits from Republican
policies and why well let me look at the
newspapers this morning then and ask you
two things either to see if you think
that this is going to help Democrats one
that Howard Dean is interested in
becoming the next head of the Democratic
National Committee Wow I like Howard
Dean and the the one of the things that
that I like most about Howard Dean was
the well I mean it was the movement that
built up around him and I thought that
was something that Democrats Democrats
definitely have to capitalize on that if
they want to part of the big problem
here is that Democrats have sort of let
them the social movement that made their
party powerful in the first place and
here I'm referring to things like the
labor movement environmental whatever
they have let those social movements
wither on the vine and that's that's
that's terrible and meanwhile the
Conservatives movement I mean the
Conservatives have been out there
building a movement from the grassroots
up ever since the late 60s they've had
enormous success at it the first thing
that Democrats have to have to do is
start working on rebuilding the
grassroots movement that made their
party possible and so in that's for that
reason I think it's very important that
they that they that they embrace the
Dean phenomenon and secondly in The
Washington Post this morning quotes John
Kerry is saying he might want to be a
candidate in 2008 well you know that's
that's great I voted for him I I liked
the guy I you know I could I could
criticize his campaign and but I don't
want to do that that's not that's not
right let's go to some phone calls all
right let's go to st. Cloud Minnesota
first good morning good morning my thing
with the Democratic Party
I have to defend myself constantly with
my Republican friends because of
abortion and the Democrats just still I
believe the Democrats do not believe in
abortion but they don't stress the fact
that we just don't believe the
government should control woman's idea
of this thing the abortion issue mm-hmm
but now as you may or may not know the
abortion issue is is the issue that
stood Kansas on its head in the
beginning in the early 90s really this
is when this is when Kansas the politics
in that state swerved dramatically to
the right and it did so directly as a
result of the way that conservatives
played the abortion issue a huge part of
the well there's there's no easy
obviously there's no easy answer to this
and that's why it's an issue that
conservatives hammer home all the time
because it's there's no easy way out of
it for for liberals and for Democrats
but I do want to suggest of that we take
a deeper look at this issue and try to
understand why it has the kind of
massive grassroots appeal on the right
that it does okay and I sort of take
this closer look in the book and I'm not
saying that I have a definitive answer
on this at all but one of the things
that really interests me about the
abortion issue is a huge part of the
anger over it is anger at judicial
activism okay not not at the specific
operation of you know abortion itself
but at the but at roe v wade at the idea
of judicial overreaching and also at the
idea of that you remember and whether
you know this or not this is the
abortion the anti I'm sorry that the
pro-life movement knows this very very
well that the roe v wade and the whole
the whole liberal argument on on on
abortion was done at the behest of the
medical community and that the world of
medicine has always been caught up in
this and so for conservatives it poses a
perfect way of setting up this kind of
populist opposition because it's not
just it's not just the people against
you know again being against abortion
it's the people against these very
specific elites the judiciary and the
medical world against
Nationals and I think this is when you
get right down to it this is the heart
of conservative populism is a form of
anti-intellectualism
okay it's replaced you're sort of old
school way of talking about class with a
new way where instead of it being you
know blue collar versus white collar
average workers against the fortune 500
it's you and me it's all of us against
these over educated people who because
they have some you know diploma on the
wall from some fancy Eastern College
they get to tell the rest of us how to
lead their lives and this is how and
this is this is immensely powerful and
it goes totally unanswered no answer
from the from from liberals from
Democrats and that is in my opinion one
of the things that makes the abortion
issue so powerful we have to figure out
a way to beat that the Wall Street
Journal editorial page this morning on
the issue of judicial and judicial
nominations and everything that's being
talked about right now says that that
President Bush is going to make the
Democrats mad anyway so he just as well
go ahead and rename innate all those
judges that he couldn't get through last
time and to make sure that he does
according to this the the editorial that
he shouldn't he shouldn't select another
blank slate like David Souter if he has
another nomination in court yeah that's
liberal media bias right there that's
liberal media speaking into that I'm
sorry I'm just kidding with them but
yeah well look he did win a majorities
got a majority in both houses of
Congress he should be able to to do what
he wants but this is what one of the
things that Democrats you say need to
would need to really I think they will
fight another point that I make in the
book and this is I can't emphasize this
enough is that conservatives win these
these smashing electoral victories every
couple of years and they do it on the
basis of values when you know it came
out on a lan election on election night
of the day after the election that the
values issues had once again triumphed
over other issues even the war on
terrorism you know these were the values
issues were more important this shocked
many people but it shouldn't have
because this is this is ongoing it's
been happening for a really long time
what fascinates me is that while these
issues are the this is how conservatives
appeal to a mass electorate this is how
they've
and over you know from the Goldwater
days to our own how they have become the
dominant party that they have and yet
once they win once they win those
elections and once they're there in
office they almost never do anything on
the cultural front on the values from
never look at Bush's first day after the
election what did he say what did his
priorities number one and this is when
they're saying look Val he won on values
issues the gay marriage thing he won
because of that he goes out there and
says I'm gonna privatize Social Security
surprise privatizing Social Security
number two I'm gonna replace the
graduated income tax with something that
doesn't weigh so heavily on on the rich
that's what they're about so it's always
this kind of this kind of bait and
switch this kind of dance so I don't
think I don't know maybe Bush will maybe
he'll gamble maybe he'll spend his
political capital trying to get roe v--
wade overturned but I'm I doubt it
Springfield Ohio good morning good
morning thanks for seein is my first
time calling so but I get to watch every
morning and it's awesome I I guess I
want to say a really respect you
anchorpersons for putting up with some
of us who call and some of us are really
out of control I think I want to throw
back to earlier for from David from
function to the President to bring more
Democrat personnel into his cabinet or
into this cabinet I think it's a great
idea I'm registered Democrat who's voted
Republican of several times including
the recent ticket and I think what our
author is saying is or I guess what
we're hearing is that Democrats have
lost a grip on what appeals to Kansas
what appeal to Ohio and and and I think
that probably being in the mix of it I'm
a self-employed person who deals with
the public is that that's because we get
burnout on the rantings week we hear
that and I even address this with
several members of the Democratic Party
locally you know I heard the last four
years I've heard grant rant rant George
Bush hatred but no real answers no real
no real ideas no real new things I've
heard lots of
first bigotry and things like this
commercials that have been aired on
radio stations locally my kids are much
younger and they're teenagers in there
they're listening to cultural hip-hop
and things like this it's it's bigotry
it's just blatant hatred and that's not
going to appeal in long-term and
thanks.thanks Ohio Frank I the promise
of it I don't know specifically what
he's talking about specifically
specifically he was talking about David
from Speas in this morning I understood
more liberal bias by the way but the
other the other I'm just kidding I
actually have great respect for David
Frum but the other thing about about the
the reverse bigotry I don't I don't know
specifically what he's referring to but
this is I want to point out that this is
also a topic that comes up constantly
when you talk to conservatives that they
believe that they are the victors real
victims that they are the true victims
of you know the world that we live in
and they are the persecuted class
they're the ones who are discriminated
against they talk about this all the
time there's even a book out right now I
think it's in paperback right now by
Rush Limbaugh's brother called it has
one of these one-word titles that
conservatives love it's called you know
arrogance treason you know this guy
this one's called persecution and the
idea is that conservative Christians are
persecuted right here right now in the
US of A that there's religious
persecution going on all about around us
and what they mean by this is that
people say mean things people say mean
things and that's persecution people
well I like like the color described and
there's no this is the the culture of
conservatism this this idea that
conservatives are the real persecuted
class is very very powerful and what
there's there's there is obviously a
grain of validity to it I mean I'm not
denying what the guy says it's true it
probably is
are you saying this is kind of a
victimhood yes they have a whole culture
of victimhood yeah absolutely
Canaan New Hampshire hello oh good
morning okay your book is right on top
I'm gonna get it as a guideline in fact
I was jotting down this morning
things that the Democrats have to
respond to they're really gob lies
because this is a used to be a
Republican status last time they went
big for Terry uh they get the union
leader there's just a Republican reg and
then no big radio station and was way
back because I grew up during the Second
World War and served in Korea so that
English teacher really explained to us
about the editorials and the propaganda
pages in the paper I mean he's these
guys make Adolf Hitler and his crew look
like purse-snatchers in fact here's one
good GOP lie they use and nobody
responds to it says oh yeah Gary's gonna
attach your social security Clinton he
text your Social Security well that is a
big lie because once you get on Social
Security you don't pay any taxes you
don't even file until you make over
twenty five thousand dollars but you see
they need a radio program a TV station
from just sorrows and a bunch of them to
counter Fox
I never sees it's a big a bunch of Lies
in my life then another Hulu and they
just started with his home ownership
well good god that started back after
the Second World War when they come out
with a GI Bill and they freed up money
and and you know the country didn't
cross the prosper because uh we won the
war approximate fifteen years later
because you give the fourteen million
veterans the GI Bill of Rights
goodbye thanks to Hampshire the reaction
to his car he raised several very
important points about taxation and
Social Security but that's kind of
that's kind of complicated but the other
the other point that he raised about
institution building that that there is
a whole network of organizations out
there on the right he mentioned he
mentioned Fox News but there's obviously
many many radio shows uh here in
Washington as I drove over here this
morning you pass you know he passes why
I didn't pass it but the Heritage
Foundation which is right over there
the Cato Institute the American
Enterprise
- in on and on and on and on and on
there's from great to small with you
know different specialties that they
focus on and there and these are all you
know lavishly funded of course by by
sort of upper-class America and there is
no counterpart on the Left I mean
there's there's nothing there there are
some very sort of weak liberal think
tanks here in DC with I mean their
hearts in the right place and I love
them but but they don't have any
anywhere near the kind of clout and this
is because conservatives very wisely
have since 1968 again there's even going
further back since 64 since the great
Goldwater disaster have put everything
they've got into institution building
and the Liberals haven't responded at
all they've done nothing or very very
little you started to see a little bit
of that this year and that's super
important that they that they that they
engage in that and that in combat on
that level
we're gonna go to Kentucky next Stearns
Kentucky good morning morning one thing
I would like to thanks he says C span
for is just before the election you had
the different candidates libertarians
Green Party socialist constitutionalists
I thought that was very interesting and
the interesting thing about it too was
the socialist and the Green Party to
take the name off and so what they were
standing for it was the same as the
Democratic Party as far as what what has
happened to the Democrats if you take
the morals of the Bible and the
Constitution the Federalist Papers which
our country was founded on they're
getting further and further away from
this just like where they become the
party of the latest Rosie O'Donnell Ted
Kennedy these are people that are devout
ante Gunners and steely hair whether
gardens the Bible mentions guns we
should have the right to protect
ourselves
John Mayer James Madison said that the
the
rats bear arms was considered necessary
to prevent a tyrannical government I
guess what we had here at at the time
our government was formed now I have a
question I have actually have a question
for the caller or just the beatitudes
the Sermon on the Mount you know where's
that what about the you know the the
rich man in the eye of the camel or have
the eye of the needle in the calf ha ha
ha well what the hell I can't forget it
what about that too early in the morning
I think I think it's it's our
responsibility as Christians to protect
ourselves and our families and after you
get if after you go home there's no
place else to go you either stand in
fight or you're slain and the our police
forces all they do is come and clean up
the mess after it's over with I think we
have a right to defend ourselves
thanks thanks Kentucky any other
reaction to well I was just thinking um
the other day I was reading I mean look
what he said about the the the the the
Democrats identifying themselves with
elitists this is this is a classic
complaint and that's you know until the
Democrats find a way of beating that
argument they're gonna continue to lose
he's basically you know he has expressed
the the sort of the attitudes that I try
to describe in the book and that's
that's great
about the Bible though I always the
thing that gets me the the sort of
spokesman for fundamentalism in the
early part of the 20th century was was a
guy called William Jennings Bryan a
Democrat a liberal by oh hell he was
more than a liberal he was this guy was
like you know bite on today's standards
way far to the left you know was openly
fought you know against imperialism
resigned from Woodrow Wilson's cabinet
in 1915 rather than have anything to do
with the First World War and he was the
you know the spokesman for
fundamentalism in America I always
wondered um well another thing the other
day I was reading the autobiography of
Lincoln Steffens is one of these you
know
books from that he was a muckraker from
the turn of the last century and it's a
book that was once very popular like in
the 1930s it's not widely read anymore
but in it he describes the first time he
read the New Testament and he couldn't
understand how anybody could could come
away after reading that and thinking
that it was a conservative document and
that it had anything to do with
upholding you know the power of of you
know of money for him it struck him as
is intensely radical and you know it's
always sort of struck me the same way I
mean I understand what the caller was
saying that this the alliance between
the between fundamentalism and a Wall
Street it just it's so unnatural it's so
unnatural Vancouver Washington
good morning mr. Frank I'm 32 years old
and I'm originally from Aurora Illinois
which unfortunately is remembered more
for its part in Wayne's world and it is
as the home of the PATCO strike which
pretty much began the destruction of the
labor movement in this country I I
proudly voted for Walt Brown of the
Socialist Party USA this election and I
was wondering what your opinion would be
about a rebirth of that movement in the
Midwest I first came across you on
c-span back in 97 and you were speaking
at the Brecht forum yeah New York
Marxist school I was learning if you
could talk about that a little also and
I've got a copy of your book one market
under God which I recommend to everyone
and I've got a copy of Baphomet number
six title page which I think Mark Hughes
you know the writer of my generation
quite frankly I think you're brilliant
and my last question would be could you
comment a little about Doug Henwood in
his book Wall Street I think here's a
man who you know forecasted the entire
financial meltdown and he never got any
press for it
that's well he said that's Doug Henwood
who he referred to there's a great
friend of mine and also one of the
one of the best economics writers of our
of our of our time and he's he's you
know he's not a trained economist so he
writes like you and me which is a huge
plus in my mind and he totally described
what would go on what happened in the
late in the new economy is in the 1990s
well before it actually took place it's
a astonishing book the book is called
Wall Street you know and it's you know
you just if you want to understand why
we are in the situation that we are and
you know instead of worrying about the
swirling clouds of you know the Liberals
are doing this and the Liberals are
controlling my life and you know that's
a pick up this book Wall Street and and
you know you'll understand you know why
things actually happened over there and
it's not a conspiracy theory it's all
journalism it's all everything is
documented fantastic stuff my own book
that he referred to one market under God
is kind of a is is a similar sort of
thing but it's about the it's about the
culture of the new economy and I wrote
it in in 98 and 99 and I would turn on
my TV to I'm one of your rival networks
there's a network in America foreign
viewers might not know this there's a
network in America that only covers the
stock market and and I remember when
they started up I couldn't believe in so
I would watch that all the time while I
was writing this book and it's about the
the kind of the culture of the new
economy the sort of the manias the funny
ideas and the the consensus about the
free-market faith and excuse me anyhow
like I I'm still very fond of this book
it's called one market under God but the
the thing that amazes me I wrote that
that came out before the crash came out
in 2000 and I described in it a
consensus between Democrats and
Republicans with the left and liberals
pretty much being out of out of the
picture about the virtues of the
free-market and this belief that the
free-market
somehow expresses the popular will that
the free market is somehow democratic
and even that Wall Street isn't more
accurate you know this the ticker of the
Dow is more a more accurate indicator of
our you know of what we think and what
we believe then is then they're actually
actual democracy itself actual elections
itself and this is a widespread faith in
the 90s what amazes me
is that in the aftermath of the collapse
that that that view hasn't gone away
hasn't even really been challenged and
that's that's extraordinary I mean we're
you know that the collapse in the Nasdaq
in 2000 2001 and then after that they
did you know the discovery of corruption
and all these sort of high-flying new
economy firms you know the staggering
refutation of all the faith's of the
1990s and and we proceed here in
Washington as though those faiths were
still intact as though nothing had
happened I mean you still don't have
anybody I mean people still believe this
kind of in this kind of market populism
this idea that markets are yes markets
are are just wonderful you know they
they they understand that the popular
voice they fix prices in an exit in a
perfectly just manner they are
omniscient you know it's the invisible
hand it's almost a deity and that view
hasn't really been challenged are you
challenging it I tried to that was four
years ago I next is Wichita Kansas all
right morning i profoundly disagree with
the left-wing viewpoint of your author
there and would suggest to the viewers
out there that if they googled the title
what's the matter with Kansas they will
discover a very famous essay written by
William Allen white in the 1890s in fact
it was used by the McKinley forces
during the campaign against the populist
he seems to enjoy so much and mr. Franks
let's mention it totally excuse me it's
mentioned in the book the we mount white
essay did not would you did not copy the
essay itself and I think it's important
for the listeners and readers out there
to actually read what mr. white had to
say a hundred and eight years ago in
terms of the problems that Kansas faced
then and arguably faces now because we
have a problem in Kansas but it's a
problem of excessive government our
income is lower than the national
average and our spending has grown so
badly out of control that the state
budget had its first billion dollar
budget in 1974 and just a couple of
years ago we went over ten billion
dollars so it's not a lack of government
we have here our problem is is that we
have too much government actually but
I'd like the author to address the fact
that his title has absconded with mr.
White's title and is in 180 degrees
opposite from the intent of the essay
and if the viewers out there want to
check it out just google and you can
pick up online
William Ellen White's very famous essay
from the 1896 was actually used by the
McKinley forces against William Jennings
Bryan thanked in the election where
Kansas went for Bryan okay thank thank
you thanks for your talk yeah that's all
that's all mentioned in the in the book
and if you go to my website you'll find
further references to it the website is
TC Frank calm I believe I even have
links that you can find we mail and
whites famous sa all over the internet
and it's also in his autobiography and
in the anthology that he put out of his
writing and I did it the reason I took
his title or used his title its homage
in one sense I hate that word its homage
it's an homage to William Allen white
who's one of the sort of my heroes and
it's also I want people to read that
essay because conservatism then had a
very different feel to it than
conservatism today the William Allen
white essay what's the matter with
Kansas is this angry attack as I said
earlier Kansas was the hotbed of
populism this kind of radical movement
and win team Allen white fresh out of
college editor of the Emporia Gazette
you know was looking around him and by
the way a staunch conservative
Republican at the time looking around
him at the state and seeing what the
populist were demanding and what they
were doing and he couldn't believe it
and the the point of his essay is you
working-class people get back in your
place and you leave us alone
we know what we're doing we the you know
the people who owned this state and it's
very very very forthright about it and
it's that you know what's the matter
with Canada and as the caller mentioned
this was picked up by the McKinley
forces and used reprinted all over the
country and millions of copies for use
against William Jennings Bryan the idea
being that that that liberals or
populist
are you know absolutely have no idea
what they're doing and this is you know
there's something well this is this is
an old way of looking at
radical movements like that today's
Republican party of course would never
ever say such a thing today it's all
there the populist and this is this is
the this is the intriguing thing he said
Kansas is today swept by another
populist movement but this one going you
know a hundred and eighty grew as a
caller mentioned a hundred and eighty
degrees different from the original one
to the point where there I found right
wingers in Kansas that are demanding the
you know to bring back the gold standard
which you will recall was one of the
populist sort of bettin wores they hated
the gold standard but now that what if
they want to bring it back damn it and
so it's another populist revolt sweeping
the state but pushing from the other the
politics all going in the other
direction but otherwise they use the
same language they rail against elites
they rail against the cosmopolitan big
cities of the coasting of the blue
states you know that and this kind of
thing centralized power the top-down
judiciary all of this stuff it is
populism but going the other direction
now one other thing I always like to
whenever you talk about William L&Y who
as I mentioned is sort of a hero of mine
you are you have to point out that
William Allen white himself changed his
opinion later and sort of how would you
put this retracted the views that he
expressed in that famous that this is
the editorial that made him famous
before that nobody knew who he was and
this made him nationally known and he
went on to become the sort of unofficial
spokesman for small-town America
and won the Pulitzer Prize I think one
at more than once and but later in life
became very became what we used to call
it progressive a left-wing Republican
and and sort of made it very explicit
that you know he he didn't so much
apologize for the views and that the
distance himself from the early views
and accepted the politics of populism
the the policies of populism if not the
actual actors where did you grow up in
Kansas Johnson County which is the
suburbs of Kansas City and it's funny
about me and populism I am I went to the
University of Kansas out of high school
and I will I'll never forget so I was I
they don't teach you at populism when
you're growing up in and
Kansas or they didn't then this is
enough you know 70s and 80s but they do
teach you about like why you're
different than the people in Missouri
right because we know who they were
they're bad Hey Kansas fought this
border war with Missouri so we know all
about that you know John Brown and all
this sort of thing but they don't teach
you they don't tell you about populism
this is a this is a tough a sticking
point in in Kansas history and there's
no monuments to it that I know of except
for one that I'd sort of described in
the book there's no real public
monuments to populism in the state but I
was and so I didn't know about it and I
was at the University of Kansas and I
was in the you know they have one of
these great libraries with open stacks
and I was I was wandering around in the
stacks and I came across a shelf of
books and it must have been 20 or 30
copies of a book called the populist
revolt published in 1931 by John Hicks
who was a great historian of that era
and and I saw him what is this why they
have 30 copies of this book and and I
pulled one down and by god it was about
Kansas and there's about stuff that it
happened in my home state and it was
about this movement that's very
sympathetic you know its average people
rising up against the powerful average
people you know sweeping through the
small towns and throwing out the stuff
this liquor you know that this the slick
small town lawyers and the kind of the
state establishment and taking over the
institutions of government by themselves
and running them in their own interest
and it's it's an inspiring story and I
had never heard it before and I've been
sort of captured by that all my life and
also by William Allen white responsible
which I should say it's it's it's also
another reason it's worth reading he was
a hell of a writer and it's a hit the
way he just took the bark off the
populist this is I mean it's a it's a
it's another thing that I that I that I
admire his ability there by the way I
also refer to it in the earlier book one
market under God I talked about his
essay what's the matter with Kansas I
refer to it all the time Mesa Arizona
good morning oh I just I haven't read
your book yet mr. Frank but I intend to
but
I wanted to say is sometimes to begin
with I'm embarrassed to be in a red
state I the thing I think that really
bothers people that vote and get out and
try to do their best if people talk as
if Bush won mm and in the final analysis
Gore won mm now they're saying oh how
easily he 104 well now it's starting to
come out with all the votes in Ohio at
one town and all this stuff and in Ohio
Kerry was drawing crowds of 90,000
60,000 80,000 only Bush had little small
crowds compared to that so I do I don't
think we're ever gonna have any coming
together in this country until we have
an honest election and that includes
getting rid of daibul and all those
machines that were purposely made so
that they could switch the votes around
and you can't they saying switch them
around and there's no way you can check
it why should America be voting like
that it makes people like me just don't
even want to vote anymore and also tell
her I'm gonna let it go at that because
we have a lot of people in line thank
you very much I you know I'm it's I
don't know about what's going on in Ohio
with the vote Kent I thought Bush won it
fair and square
but then again you know that's what it
said in the New York Times
although whose side they're on right go
ahead Forsyth I would like mr. prank
caller I'm sorry
I'm going to have to make you turn down
your television set all the way if you
don't we're getting a lot of feedback we
can't even hear you I understand thank
you I would like mr. Franks definition
of values and morality he is a wordsmith
does that apply just to the religious
right or religious people just give us a
few words as described in Webster's
dictionary applied
- morality and values wow this is
something where I'm no good at at giving
Webster's definitions of things I'm
sorry but I I would say that the caller
maybe the caller has a definition
herself did it okay um yeah I'm sorry I
don't I don't have one but I will say
this at though that the word values is
is code for culture wars we all know you
know what that means whether it's gay
marriage this year or flag-burning and
back in 1988 or you know it we all know
what that what we mean by the culture
wars and this is a phenomenon that
fascinates me always has because on the
one hand it's you know so deeply
resonant and so you know powerful all of
these issues and then on the other hand
it always winds up electing people whose
values I mean and then the caller's sort
of started to suggest this whose values
are our Wall Street's values you know
and that's a different way of using the
word value where it's just about the
dollar sign and do liberals have values
well I know I do I'm a liberal and I
think that liberals could easily reclaim
that the values debate that look the
thing is that we have to fight this
battle the electoral battle we have to
fight the same way Republicans have
Democrats have to figure out ways to
fracture the Republican coalition in the
same way you know this is what this is
what wedge issues a another term for the
values values issues cultural issues is
wedge issues and what this what that's
what this means what this describes is
an issue that you use to fracture to
break off bits of the old New Deal
coalition okay and that's the idea
behind all of these cultural warriors
uses get this little segment of the old
Democratic coalition with this issue get
that segment with that issue none of
these issues appeal to a large majority
you know not even the abortion issue the
most powerful wedge issue of them all
these these people are still the the
pro-lifers are still I think a minority
in in terms of the actual population but
it's very effective in hammering the
Democratic coalition Democrats have to
do this they have to find the weak
points in the Republican coalition and
strike at those points now do you mind
if I keep
there let me just say what that weak
point is as long as I've brought this up
the Republican coalition is two groups
on the one hand traditional business
Republicans Wall Street gave more money
to Bush this year than ever before
because they want that Social Security
money and they're going to get it and
then the other part of the coalition is
the Family Values Voters the the culture
war voters who were tend to be
blue-collar people who have been brought
over from the sort of traditional
loyalty to the Democratic Party have
been brought over to the Republicans by
by the values issues and look these two
groups really don't have that many
interests in common okay the way you the
way you break this coalition apart is by
talking about how their interests
conflict and their interests conflict in
a lot of ways now the problem is to talk
about that you've got to talk about the
role of business in our culture you got
to talk about the power of Wall Street
you have to talk about this sort of you
know those that old-school economic
populism that Democrats have tried to be
getting away from they've been trying
sorry they've been trying to get away
from for quite a while now so where does
that leave us
beats me yeah I'm one of those liberals
up there in the blue states a total
security sorry but I was born in Kansas
in fact all my sisters I was born
Harrington and Wichita and make first
and those should bring about but since
then it like you moved on my father was
a minister and but but the thing that it
gets me about the division in this
country is is the Republicans like
you're saying you know people like
marine we're a mcdowell wrote a column
I'm sorry I mispronounced your name
about how how pathetic it is how they
you know late the Republicans use these
wedge issues just like Howard Dean said
so well God guns and gays and that's
what it's come down to and they make
these divisions when really you know
Bush is the cowboy image that they
Hills to them but really it just guises
this this you know Wall Street
fundamentalism you know for the
Republicans really that they they really
are for money and and wealth and and
keeping that from the middle class
Buffalo broken let me just ask you a
question your relatives your relatives
in Kansas in those towns in Harrington
and McPherson which I presume are pretty
small right how do how do they feel
about the Democrats or liberals who
would live in an area like mister
Franklin in the Mission Hills the the
suburbs of Kansas City well I actually
moved we all move when we were I was we
were all born there then we moved up my
father had a pastor he was a pastor he
moved up to New York and so we were
raised in the north I say no but you
know we traveled back to Kansas and I
and I can I can recall the wonderful
feeling that you know values and all
that I can I can understand it but what
I don't understand is how you know I'm
not pro-abortion no liberal is
pro-abortion it's it's that we want
people to have choice in this country
that's what our democracy was founded on
that's what Howard Dean wanted to get
back to and that's what Kerry was trying
to say it just just didn't get through I
mean you how do you break through I I
just you know being as a person of faith
I just don't see fundamentally how we
can live in the United States and not be
able to see the issues in a more
objective manner mr. Frank thank you mr.
Frank she made your argument yes that's
I thought that was very eloquent and and
well put and I I would like to talk
about what you what you were what you
think well let me first say that uh I go
back to Kansas all obviously all the
time you know cuz I wrote the book I
love it there it's funny I you know it's
just it's in some ways I'm just totally
at peace when I'm there
it's funny how much I like the place
kisses you politically I'm so out of
step with the majority there but I would
say that Mission Hills is a long way
from from from Wichita oh yeah from
Wichita but talking about big cities how
about those really tiny ones in the
western part of the state yeah well
they've you know they're those a lot of
those towns are have been really really
hard hit I mean we should point out to
viewers first of all that what you're
referring to Mission Hills is a little
suburb that I grew up in and it's very
small and super super affluent it's one
of those kind of things like a gated
community only no a little bigger and
built in the 1920s before they had such
things and anyhow it's for people in
Kansas it's a for people in the Kansas
City area anyway and for I guess for a
lot of the rest of the state it's a
symbol of concentrated wealth and that's
what it is it is the state's elite or a
big part of the state's a elite living
next door to each other I mean the
corporate elite I mean and I and I
describe this in the book that these
people live just a few doors down from
one another you know this guy run this
corporation X this guy runs corporation
Y you know all these millionaires yeah
Wichita anyhow um when I would talk to
people when I would talk to
conservatives and as I said that the
divide between the conservatives and the
moderates in Kansas as a class or his it
boils down essentially to a class divide
they would you know we would talk about
Mission Hills we talk about the
symbolism of that and what you
constantly find is this confusion of
that with liberalism of this disk of
this this distaste for financial elites
and for the people who and they know who
they know who that is they know who
people who are who live in Mission Hills
and that they're very wealthy and that
they own the state and they own you know
that they what they say goes and they
have power and you don't but when they
describe them they always say those
liberals and that's a very you know in
point of fact they aren't liberals the
neighborhood went for Goldwater by like
70 percent went for Bush by 7 in the
Latino Oh went by 70 percent for Bush I
don't know what it did this time but I
thought that was a very telling you know
that that confused
and because in their eyes these people
are liberals they tend to be moderate
Republicans they're pro-choice you know
they're if you meet them they seem like
you know very tolerant individuals and
highly educated highly educated right
and they they fit the kind of the blue
state stereotype you know they have
Volvo's they like imported products you
know all that sort of stuff but they
vote Republican anyhow this is the book
what's the matter with Kansas how
conservatives won the heart of America
our guest has been Thomas Frank thanks
very much for joining us my pleasure
it's a lot of fun and you have a new
baby that's right we have a baby born on
Friday
congratulations thank you